I think some
people uh just maybe earlier in their
career or earlier in life they haven't
they don't know necessarily what they
like maybe they haven't tried enough
things or whatever it may be and they're
still kind of searching for that passion
do you have any advice for people that
are still searching and trying to find
that thing
yes first um TR look there's two things
there's
your cerebral
um logical mind and then your
subliminal emotional
mind and there's your nature okay both
all these things are at work so first
know your nature I put out um a I
created and put out a uh personality
profile uh exercise called principle you
it's free
online take it take a look at it know
your nature because if you have a sense
of what is your nature you H and that
nature will give you really good ideas
in terms of where you should go like
there are certain careers or them
certain types of things that are more
suitable for you that are naturally your
nature and also it'll help you deal with
others so knowing getting a sense of
what is your nature there's some people
who are more left brain some that are
more right brained and so on you know
that nature and then um you taste things
and you find the pull but you at the
same time you want to do it that pull is
like an emotional subliminal thing that
pulls you and at the same time you want
to make sure that you intellectually
align those things like you just just
don't want to go after the things that
are going to give you your passion um if
they don't give you um other things I'm
like I the principle make your work and
your passion the same thing and don't
forget about the money part because the
money part but you have to have your
nature your passion your work I mean if
you make those two things the same time
you're going to be good and if you can
do it in an area that makes you money so
that money gives you freedom and safety
and gives you those things it's a good
thing you need to if you align those
things with your nature you're going to
do it so it's that kind of a discovery
process that you should have